je roule un petit village situé au sud
ouest de l'irlande
c'est ici que sophie toscan du plantier
et retrouvée morte le 23 décembre 1996
défiguré le crâne fracassé
elles portent des traces de blessures de
défense la dernière trace d'elle vivant
remonte à dimanche vers 23 heures quand
elle a apparemment donné un coup de
téléphone et son corps a été retrouvé
hier matin vers 10 heures l'enquète
démarre très vite un homme attire les
soupçons ian bailey un journaliste
anglais des griffures sont constatées
sur son corps autre élément troublant
il couvre la sphère dans un journal
local et dans ses articles des détails
connus seulement des enquêteurs malgré
ses dénégations il ya une b lire est le
suspect numéro un du meurtre
seulement aucune preuve scientifique ne
le relie au crime
mieux sa femme lui fournit même un alibi
et pour les griffures
il ya une belle et donne une explication
inattendue
ils avaient passé la nuit du crime chez
lui affirme sa compagne et les griffures
qu'il portait au visage au lendemain du
meurtre proviendrait des dindons qui se
débattent forcément quand on les attrape
pendant des années les investigations
s'enlise en irlande
de son côté la france ouvre sa propre
enquête des années plus tard en 2008 et
en 2010 elle délivre un mandat d'arrêt
international contre ian bailey
pour la mère de la victime c'est une
avancée importante
ça fait 13 ans que nous attendons ça
alors c'est long et c'est pas la honte
parce que nous la mort de sophie c'est
son absence si vous voulez on s'y
habitue pas pour la famille l'espoir est
de courte durée lee 2012
nouveau rebondissement la cour suprême
irlandaise refuse d'extrader ian bailey
par la france je suis bien sûr soulagé
que cette procédure soit arrivé à son
terme car vous savez j'ai vraiment vécu
une période difficile
encore une fois l'en tête piétine c'est
un nouveau coup dur pour la famille de
la victime mais une solution existe pour
extrader ian bailey l'ouverture d'un
procès en france
2019 c'est chose faite mais sans la
présence de l'accusé
verdict ian bailey est condamné par
défaut à 25 ans de réclusion criminelle
après
et 22 ans d'attentes 22 ans de
souffrance 22 ans de questions les juges
ont condamné ian bailey qui a tué ma
mère
ce combat la famille de sophie toscan du
plantier le continue aujourd'hui elle
est toujours en attente d'une
extradition de ian bailey
[Musique]